good afternoon welcome I am Ernesto
Zedillo director of the Yale Center for
the Study of globalization today is a
very special day for us we have
president Larry Summers of Harvard or
should I say secretary summers and this
is a great honor for us I don't think I
need to make a long introduction of
president summers he has a very
distinguished career both in academia
and in public service a very well-known
personality in this country not only in
this country but all over the world
probably you know that he was educated
at MIT and Harvard although he had a
very good beginning by being born in New
Haven Connecticut and as I said he has a
very distinguished academic career first
as a professor of at MIT then professor
at Harvard University where actually he
happened to be one of the youngest
person ever to be given tenure at a
rather early age he is author of more
than 100 professional articles in a
number of fields in macroeconomics in
public finance labor economics
International Economics and also in
international relations president
Summers is a very distinguished
specialist on topics such as
transatlantic relations he has had very
impressive academic honors he was the
first social scientists ever to receive
the annual Alan T Waterman award of the
National Science Foundation and he was
also a recipient of the John Bates Clark
medal given
two years to the other outstanding
American economies younger than 40 years
old he's a career in public service is
equally impressive been a rather very I
was a very young economist he was a part
of the President's Council of Economic
Advisers later on he was vice president
and chief economist at the World Bank
then at the beginning of the Clinton
administration he was appointed under
secretary for international affairs at
the Treasury later he was appointed
deputy secretary of the Treasury in 1995
and then Secretary of the Treasury in
1999 it was precisely during his time at
the Treasury where I had the privilege
of meeting president summers and
unfortunately for me it was not only
meeting him but at the time Mexico was
enduring
a terrible economic crisis and I said
unfortunately because it was such a
tough time that fortunately we went
through that difficult time successfully
and that was the case to some extent to
some no minor Eastern thanks to the
assistance that we received from the US
government and let me tell you that
president Summers was very important for
us at that very difficult complex moment
for Mexican history so please join me in
welcoming professor Summers who will be
speaking this afternoon on the u.s.
current account deficit and the global
economy which is a terribly important
topic for today's state of the world
thank you
thank you very much mr. president for
that very kind introduction it reminds
me slightly of the question I used to be
asked when I was in Washington which was
what's the difference between being the
president being professor at a
university and working at the Treasury
Department and I would say there are
many differences but one very important
one is that a university as a professor
the worst thing you can do is sign your
name to something you didn't write you
know what's coming on the other hand as
a Treasury official it was a mark of
effectiveness to do so as frequently as
possible
and now that I have returned I also
perceive some similarities and some
differences one similarity is that I
have not left political life I think
about that for a second a important
difference is that I can today talk
about what is a very big problem and it
is less obligatory on me to propose a
solution and that is a luxury that I
will take advantage of but before I say
anything else this being in academic
setting I want to tell one story and
it's a story that I think points up the
importance of the kind of research that
people do here and people do at Harvard
and at other great universities in the
course of Mexico's financial
difficulties and the u.s. support
program Ernesto and I I think are the
only two people on the planet who do not
use the term bailout to refer to what
took place at what might have been the
darkest hour in that period when things
were really very very complicated you
know whole set of ways President Clinton
and secretary Rubin asked me to go to
Mexico to meet with President Cedillo
and to discuss the situation in detail
it was a very it was a very tense moment
in the air for subject flew me there and
they we didn't want this to become
public then so I was snuck into the
residence where presidents India was
we discussed a number of things and I
remember a lot of parts of our
conversation but what I remember most
was that there was a discussion of what
Mexican monetary policy should be in the
face of the problem and the question
arose as to how high interest rates
should be increased and so forth and
president cedilla looked at me and he
said you know I think you're basically
right in pushing us to have higher
interest rates and I will follow up on
that but you know it's much more
complicated than a lot of people suggest
because there are adverse selection
models and there are moral hazard models
and he then proceeded to take me through
the micro economic theory of credit
rationing in considerable difficulty I
think he understood a hundred percent of
what he was saying I think I understood
eighty-five percent of what he was
saying I think the staff members from
the State Department who were with me
and from the Mexican presidency who were
with him understood about five percent
of what either of us was saying but it
did remind me because it was a very
tense moment of the importance and the
centrality of the kind of basic thinking
that goes on about economic and social
processes in a university believe me it
was not an academic exercise that
morning and it was very much a
discussion of the product of academic
research what I'd like to do this
afternoon is to talk for a little while
about an issue that I think should be
receiving very considerable thought in
international fora and that I think
should be debated in the course of the
u.s. presidential campaign and that is
the u.s. current account deficit and so
Shadid reliance on foreign borrowing and
its implications for the global economy
I'm gonna try to answer to ask and to
answer four questions first is the u.s.
current account deficit a large issue
that will continue without a
discontinuity and I will answer yes
second is the large and growing US
current account deficit as some suggests
a sign of economic strength or instead a
situation that is quite problematic and
I will suggest that it is quite
problematic third is the current
reliance for financing of the u.s.
current account deficit on official
intervention a state of affairs which is
either desirable or sustainable and I
shall suggest that it is neither
desirable nor sustainable and forth I
shall ask what is to be done first the
numbers the u.s. current account deficit
is now running a little bit over six
hundred billion dollars a year that
represents five and a half percent of
the GDP of the United States it
represents about one and a quarter
percent of the GDP of the world and the
United States is absorbing about two
thirds of the combined current account
surplus of all the countries in the
world that are running current account
surpluses all of these numbers are
without present the United States has
never run a five and a half percent of
GDP turns account deficit no country in
the world has ever run a current account
deficit in excess of one percent of
world GDP nor
as any country single-handedly absorbed
more than two-thirds of the capital that
has been exported by the capital
exporting countries of the world will it
continue is it somehow a transient
economic series go up they go down is
this just part of a cyclical fluctuation
I fear not in round numbers the United
States is now importing just over
sixteen percent of its gross domestic
product it is exporting a bit less than
eleven percent of its gross domestic
product so imports are 50% larger than
exports this has a arithmetic
implication that is not less disturbing
for being very simple suppose the global
economy grows in a completely balanced
way the income of all countries Rises
uniformly world trade in all directions
Rises uniformly with global income each
$1 increase in US exports is then
associated with a dollar-fifty increase
in US imports or to put the point
differently if over a five-year period
US imports and exports both were to grow
at 6% and the US economy were to grow at
3% our current account deficit would
deteriorate by 1% of GDP but the
situation is actually significantly
worse than this for two reasons because
US labor force growth and US
productivity growth is running more
strongly than labor force growth and
productivity growth in most of our major
trading partners extra growth in the
United States will suck in imports at a
rate that exceeds the demand for us
exports arising from growth in other
countries second and probably more
important quantitatively as a magnifier
is the phenomenon that economists don't
fully understand but have labeled as the
how tack our McGee effect it is that
when I described it you will see that it
is not a phenomenon you would
necessarily predict and it has been it
was first noticed in 1969 and people
have said it's a data aberration that
will disappear in the next business
cycle for 35 years now and that how
tacker mcgee effect is simply this
observation the elasticity of US imports
with respect to US income substantially
exceeds the elasticity of foreign
imports with respect to foreign income
so while I described the situation where
balance growth led to a balanced
increase in international trade the
likelihood is the growth is likely to be
unbalanced in a direction which further
unbalances trade and that even if growth
were balanced the result would be that
the extra demand for imports coming from
American growth would exceed the extra
demand for exports coming from foreign
growth taking all this together the
results of the various modeling
exercises that are done should not be
very surprising these modeling exercises
are not really forecasts since what
happens to the current account deficit
depends upon how economies evolve and
how exchange rates move they'd rather
efforts to judge the sustainability of
the current situation so the question
they ask
is what happens if current income trends
continue and current exchange rates are
maintained and the numbers are
attention-getting
the most recent such study that I've
read is that of Nouriel Roubini and Brad
Setzer at the Institute for
International Economics who predict that
without a discontinuity the u.s. current
account deficit will rise to six and a
half percent of GDP in 2006 and 7.8
percent of GDP in 2008 using a different
model and a somewhat different
methodology Catherine Mann predicts a
current account deficit that could reach
thirteen percent of GDP by 2010 without
some kind of major discontinuity note
carefully these are not forecasts of
what will occur they are descriptions of
the implication of the current path and
if you regard the prospect of a 13
percent current account deficits in 2010
as unlikely some implication should be
drawn for the current path one can of
course argue about the numbers and one
can question various aspects of the
calculation but I am aware of no
credible argument that without some form
of significant discontinuity the u.s.
current account deficit will remain
level let alone decline from its current
high level there is a second question
that must be asked with respect to a
major current account deficit is the
current account deficit a sign of
economic vitality or of incipient
problems there is the famous observation
of one finance minister of a country
that was experiencing a substantial
current account deficit and associated
capital inflows
he said would I rather be the finance
minister of a country that capital was
trying to get into where the finance
minister of a country the capital was
trying to get out of and it is a valid
point the fact that a country is
borrowing does not necessarily mean that
there is a major problem and so there
are a set of classic tests that one uses
in looking at a current account deficit
to judge whether it is a sign of
economic problems or whether it is a
reflection of opportunity the point
about reflection of opportunity is a
very real one after all
think about the difference between a
company that is borrowing substantially
to take account of large new profitable
investment opportunities and a company
that is borrowing in order to meet its
payroll the former is a sign of
opportunity the latter a sign of serious
problems how does one look at a country
and make such an assessment the
calculation is much more frequently done
and the question is much more frequently
asked with respect to emerging market
countries than with respect to large
powers like the United States but it is
nonetheless instructive to ask some of
the questions that would be asked of an
emerging market country the kinds of
questions that were asked and must be
said not answered very satisfactorily
during 1994 before the problems in
Mexico that President Cydia did such a
wonderful job of cleaning up first
question does the current account
deficit and the increase in the current
account deficit reflect a increase in a
country's level of investment or
does it reflect a reduction in its
savings associated with increased public
and private consumption here the answer
is very clear in the last year the net
national savings rate of the United
States that is to say all of the saving
that households have done plus the
savings the corporations have done in
the form of retained earnings less the
savings that have been absorbed by
government borrowing has represented
less than 2% of GDP that is the lowest
figure in American history it is the
lowest national savings figure for any
major country since the Second World War
it represents a national savings rate
about half the rate that took place in
the early 1990s when budget deficits and
lack of national saving were last an
American preoccupation the decline in
the net national savings rate accounts
entirely for the reduction in for the
u.s. current account deficit that is to
say if one looks at the net investment
rate in the United States in 2000 and
the net investment rate in 2004 the net
investment rate has declined
significantly even as the current
account deficit has risen substantially
a second question that one naturally
asks in looking at a current account
deficit is what is happening to
investment in the sectors of the economy
that are most important for ultimately
paying back the debt that is incurred is
investment in the traded goods sector or
is investment in the non traded
sector here too the data speak all too
clearly and not in an encouraging way an
unusual interest rate environment and
heavy foreign competition in
manufacturing has changed the
composition of investments in the United
States substantially towards the
non-traded goods sector has manifested
particularly clearly in the dramatic
increases in the price of residential
real estate in and around most major
American cities so savings has fallen
investment has not increased investment
has shifted out of the traded goods
sector there's one final question that
one would ask in looking at an emerging
market country what is the form in which
the financing of the current account
deficit is coming are there whatever the
circumstances in terms of savings and
investment are their private long term
investors who are prepared to make a
major commitment to the nation in
question or it does the financing of the
current account deficit as Mexico's did
in 1994 coming substantially from
official intervention here - there are
plenty of issues for economists to
debate in the figures but the basic
picture is relatively clear red Stetzer
has calculated that if one looks at the
BIS annual report on reserves that the
resent central banks of Asia inclusive
of Japan increased their reserves by
between from 1.1 trillion dollars in the
end of 2001 to 1.8 trillion dollars at
the end of 2003
100 billion dollar increase with Japan's
reserves increasing by 265 billion
dollars
China's reserves by a hundred and ninety
1 billion dollars
India's reserves by 52 billion dollars
and the reserves of the newly
industrialised economies by a hundred
and sixty three billion dollars at the
end of 2003 the reserves of Taiwan
exceeded the reserves of all of Latin
America the evidence from this year is
less clear because the figures have not
been fully compiled and there may have
been some reduction in the extent of
reserve accumulation but the basic
picture is that the u.s. current account
deficit is being financed in substantial
part in some quarters a hundred percent
in others 1/3 by foreign sent for
initial intervention by the official
sector in other countries purchasing US
Treasury bills there are different terms
that can be applied to this system
Michael Dooley Peter Garber and David
Falk Ritz Landau have referred to it as
a new Bretton Woods system
analogizing it with the workings of the
economic system in the late 1960s when
foreign purchases of dollars were
supporting the price of gold Catherine
Mann has described it as codependency we
are dependent on their purchases of our
debt securities they are dependent on
our market for their products perhaps
another term for it that I prefer is
international vendor finance it's
relatively clear what's going on a
number of countries
particularly China our maintaining a
fixed or a quasi fixed exchange rate
through very substantial exchange rate
intervention and enjoying strong export
performance to the United States the
price of that strong export performance
is maintenance of the exchange rate
through massive intervention for time
such a strategy may well have been
justified certainly the right lesson to
learn from the Asian financial crises
was that illiquidity could come at any
moment and that reserves were prudent
and prudent to a greater extent than had
been supposed before but what one is
talking about 700 billion dollars of
reserve accumulation in two years one is
talking about reserve accumulation that
goes way beyond the necessary or
desirable capacity to roll-your-own IMF
program nor looking at the return that
is earned on these reserves which after
all is negative in real dollar terms
Treasury bills paying under 2% US
inflation running at 3% and negative in
local currency terms if an appreciation
it takes place is it reasonable to
suppose that the primary motivation of
these for the accumulation of these
reserves is that they represent the
highest value investment opportunity
open to the societies that are investing
on such a scale large current account
deficits then in the United States are
growing they are replacing declining US
savings with substantial short-term
official sector financed from other
parts of the world particularly Asia
my third question is an arrangement of
this kind desirable if it can be
maintained and if desirable in some
respects is it likely to be sustainable
over the medium and long term I'll
already hinted at some of the concerns
consider first whether it would be
desirable if it could be maintained for
the United States
this arrangement carries with it two
very substantial risks one is that the
incipient protectionist pressures that
are generated by a large trade deficit
will ultimately increase the political
pressure on the United States in a
protectionist direction you see it in
the current furor over outsourcing which
commands so much attention in this
political year it's one who's had a
chance to observe the process for fairly
closely for twelve years now there's no
question in my mind that protectionist
pressures in the United States are on a
significant upwards trend the second
risk for the United States of this
system is no less real if more amorphous
inevitably dependence on foreign
governments for short-term financing has
to raise questions and create
vulnerabilities in both the economic and
political realms the question can fairly
be asked how long should the world's
greatest power remain the world's
greatest borrower how long will the
world's greatest borrower remain the
world's greatest power I've previously
used the term balance of financial
terror
refer to a situation where we where we
rely on the costs of others not
financing our current account deficit as
assurance that that financing will
continue the term balance of financial
Terror may overdramatize the problem but
surely this must be a situation of
concern if these arrangements are
problematic for the United States they
are not less so in the medium run for
those providing the financing here to a
question of desirability arises from as
I already mentioned the very low return
that is earned on substantial reserve
accumulation to repeat the real interest
rate earned in dollar terms in countries
with vast and attractive investment
opportunities is negative and even the
most modest currency appreciation will
create a situation where the nominal
return earned on hundreds of billions of
dollars of reserves will be negative
second and the significance of this will
vary from country to country there is as
always with fixed exchange rate regimes
the loss of domestic monetary control
and the difficulty of adjusting monetary
policy to domestic conditions
retrospectives on the catastrophic
Japanese speculative bubble of the late
1980s which set the stage for Japan's
Lost Decade
in the 1990s place very substantial
emphasis on the monetary consequences of
efforts to maintain the value of the end
and prevent an appreciation of the end
in the period after the stock market
crash of 1987
one sees similar phenomena in China
where the external constraints exert an
important impact on domestic monetary
policy creating massive liquidity
flowing in to Chinese asset markets the
current arrangements are also highly
problematic for Europe with a limited
number of currencies that are flexible
against the dollar the flexible
currencies will bear disproportionately
the impact of any changes in sentiment
regarding dollar assets international
vendor finance is to be sure a not
without its virtues low-cost finance for
America at a time when savings are low
strong exports and very competitive
traded goods sectors for those who
provide the finance but one that has as
I've suggested very substantial costs
and then there is the question of the
sustainability of the arrangements the
comparison is made to the Bretton Woods
regime but as Barry Eichengreen notes in
his very perceptive paper on this
subject the Bretton Woods regime took
place at a time when the United States
had a current account surplus not a
current account deficit Bretton Woods
regime took place in an era of
substantially less capital mobility than
we expect and we enjoy today and the
Bretton Woods regime did after all end
and not in an easy way when and in what
way does the regime does this regime of
rising current account deficits and
increasing US reliance on official
sector finance and whether it will end
on its own accord is impossible to
predict but I would suggest that if one
seeks to draw lessons from the last 15
years of monetary experience
here is one that is very powerful fixed
exchange rates with heavy intervention
have enormous capacity to create an
illusory sense of stability that then
shatters very quickly that is the lesson
of Brazil in 1992 a Britain in 1992 of
Mexico in 1994 of emerging Asia in 1997
of Russia in 1998 of Brazil in 1998 of
Argentina in 2000 and of Turkey more
recently to be sure there are important
differences between exchange rates that
are being protected against pressure for
depreciation by official intervention
and exchange rates that are being
protected against pressure for
appreciation by the creation of
liquidity most obviously you can run out
of reserves you can't run out of the
capacity to print your own money but the
basic point I believe remains valid
governments find that a calculus of
costs and benefits that heavily weighs
political costs does not support
adjustment of an unsustainable exchange
rate absent crisis or great financial
pressure to do so but by the time
adjustment is compelling it is too late
for it to be managed easily this is a
movie we have seen many times in the
international financial system large
current account deficits current
accounts deficits that replace savings
and are financed officially in a system
and unlikely to endure as death
accumulates what is to be done
there is to be sure the strategy of
averting the gaze not seeking to raise
questions hoping that flows will
continue and waiting until the day when
they don't I would suggest that this is
a risky course it's not a course whose
consequences are easy to predict it's
not easy to predict when there will be
when there is will be a problem or if
there will be a problem over the next
several years whether the problem will
take the form of a need to raise
interest rates sharply in the United
States a dramatic increase in
protectionist pressures or difficulties
of monetary control in the Asian
economies one can't predict any of these
things with great consequence great
confidence but it seems to me that the
risk of adverse consequences along the
road is such that it is prudent to think
about managing the situation in some
planned way of course one of the great
glories of being an academic rather than
a policymaker is that one can simply
exhort others to formulate the right
plan for defusing the situation but I
would make five observations the first
is that I will have served my purpose
today if I have stimulated thought about
the fact that there is a major issue
that needs to be resolved globally and I
am more confident of that conclusion
than of any of the other particular
conclusions that I'm going to offer
second it seems to me that if these
matters are to be addressed and I shall
argue in just a moment that they need to
be addressed on an international basis
they will need to be just addressed
outside of the g7 which has been the
traditional fora for considering issues
of
this kind the g7 has a track record that
is in some respects strong but the g7
does not include and does not
substantially represent China many of
the major Asian countries and emerging
markets that are central to the u.s.
current account deficit and central to
the future of the global economy it
would be my hope that reflection on the
problems that I have discussed today
would take place in other global fora
indeed it seems to me that we have come
rather more quickly than I had expected
in the late 1990s when I was involved in
the establishment of the g20 group
involving the 20 major financial powers
- a situation where there are important
issues of global economic consideration
for the g20 countries to consider that
are not primarily about what industrial
countries are going to bail out which
other emerging market countries but
rather with respect to the overall
global economic strategy for sustained
growth third observation a significant
increase in u.s. national savings is a
is a necessary but not a sufficient
response to the problems that I have
described it is necessary as a necessary
response because it is difficult to
imagine an adequate rate of US
investment or an appropriate rate of
interest in the United States with
national savings below 2% and the
removal of substantial foreign finance
but it is not a sufficient response to
the global imbalance because it we
dueces global demand and because in
particular it reduces the demand for US
products and so a concomitant of the
necessary increase in u.s. national
savings whether it takes place as I
expected must through substantial
reduction in the US budget deficit or
whether it takes place naturally through
adjustments in personal and private
savings these policies that will promote
growth abroad and and the switching of
demand from other countries towards the
United States indeed without such
policies an increase in u.s. national
savings could simply call forth greater
intervention and greater official
finance of the United States with even
more adverse monetary consequences for
the nations that are seeking to peg
their exchange rates an additional
concomitant of a healthy strategy must
therefore be a coordinated adjustment of
exchange rates that are currently quasi
fixed to the dollar the argument is
sometimes made that the current system
runs the risk of pressure arising for
its end not unlike the pressures that
arose at the end of the Bretton Woods
system where some nations will weary of
holding and accumulating dollar assets
given what they judged to be the low
expected returns and we'll make a
currency adjustment and then others
seeing on the handwriting on the wall
will follow this is one possible aspect
of the situation another which I judge
to be rather the greater risk is that
unilateral exchange rate adjustments
will be delayed for a very long time
because of the very substantial
competitive pressures against those who
allow a unilateral exchange rate
appreciation and so exchange rate
appreciation is likely to be more
politically acceptable and more
economically excessive acceptable if it
does not take place unilaterally but
takes place in a coordinated fashion
this too is a remedy that does not work
very well on its own an exchange rate
adjustment in Asia and an associated
substantial reduction in foreign
purchases of u.s. American US Treasury
bills will put American interest rates
and the American recovery at significant
risk without with risks to the low
global economy unless at the same time
there is increased national savings to
take over the demand for those u.s. debt
securities when one thinks about the
problem carefully it seems to me that
both elements of the necessary
adjustment process and increase in u.s.
national savings and an adjustment of
currently fixed exchange rates are much
easier and healthier with the
complimentary measure and that is of
course the classic case for policy
coordination when measures which are
desirable taken jointly are not
desirable or seem risky taken
individually it would be my hope that in
the not-too-distant future through some
set of discussions through some set of
coordination tacit or explicit we find
our way to such a set of adjustments
fifth and finally one of the things that
I have been quite struck by is the
changing character of
international discourse for some years
during the Cold War it was preoccupied
almost entirely with matters military
for much of the 1990s it was preoccupied
almost entirely with matters economic
perhaps in retrospect to an excessive
extent but I fear that today the world
has shifted pendulum has again swung too
far and that as we debate the
geostrategic
challenges in the Middle East and
elsewhere it is crucial that we not lose
sight of looming economic difficulties
that as history suggests could
ultimately have very profound political
consequences thank you very much
I'm not sure sure China
tn thank you for your compliment and
thank you thank you for your compliments
I'm not sure I'm going to be able to do
justice to your to your question we all
kind of have our things and lots of
issues whatever they are have a tendency
for me to come back to something about
u.s. national savings of the US budget
deficit and for you kind of whatever the
issue is that tends to be an answer that
goes to good structural microeconomic
reform to free up markets in India and
other developing countries so we all
have our things that I think you're
right in your basic and clinic in your
basic inclination I don't presume to
understand the Indian situation as well
as you do I think I understand the
Chinese situation a little bit better
your basic point which is that in any
society that's in societies that are
labor rich and capital for with
potentially enormous ly important and
attractive investment opportunities to
clean the air to build infrastructure to
educate girls to do what happen there is
something tragic about the massive
accumulation of Treasury bills yielding
1% and then the question is why is it
happened and there are presumably a
combination of factors the factory you
emphasize in the Indian context as well
look there are all these hugely
attractive investment opportunities but
the government hasn't so screwed up that
you can make the investment in the
society when we better off but you can't
be confident that you'll actually get
the return from the investment so people
don't invest adequately and that's no
doubt a part of the story and no doubt
somewhat different set of property
rights
are also a problem in China I think a
different part of the answer is that
there is actually a desire to maintain a
hyper-competitive exchange rate for
standard mercantile kind of reasons that
it is strongly supportive of the export
sectors and my guess is the political
economy of biased towards the export
sectors of those economies as part of a
development strategy probably explains a
little more of that intervention than
weakness is there the prospect of it
being adjusted I don't know it's a very
funny kind of system where you have the
strong being so dependent for Finance on
the weak and that makes the nature of
Ravens really quite unlike anything
before I suspect in the media somewhat
utopian idea that the opportunity to be
part of being a genuine partner with the
United States in addressing a matter
that is a substantial global concern in
the context of significant US
adjustments as well could actually be an
important spur to some kind of agreement
and that's why I put as much emphasis
if you look at the decline and if you
look at the figures on u.s. national
savings u.s. private saving has been
trending downwards for nearly 20 years
some of it is has to do with the fact
that over some gaming part of the period
the stock market was strong and that was
creating a wealthy fact which was
pushing consumption some of it is that
there is more ability to borrow than
there used to be and so people are
operating and that reduces personal
saving some of it is probably that all
the refinancing that's been possible
with interest rates have fallen has led
to increase in spending it is hard to
know what will happen to the personal
savings rate going forward you can look
and it sort of trended downwards from
nine to one over the last twenty years
and you know sometimes when things are
trending to keep trendy and sometimes
things are trending they revert back to
the mean and who thinks they know the
answer that question is that with
complete confidence is probably wrong
the more potent and reliable way is to
address the budget deficit that goes to
very basic questions about fiscal policy
in there isn't actually any miracle
about it it's actually rather simple
- the difference between the amount of
expense and the amount of government
collects taxes if you want to reduce the
budget deficit you have to either spend
less or tax more it's a question of
values not macroeconomics which one of
those you choose and the question is is
that likely to happen here does the work
of Reason in a democracy and wallet just
rates or 4% it's not easy to get people
alarmed about the budget deficit but
hopefully there will be some winners
however many people
controlling so my question is what is
your view on the picture first there is
this common idea that international
financial crises are caused by all those
around
let's be very clear about the actual
national financial crisis in every case
the country in question wasn't an
innocent overwhelmed by a flood of
hotline
it made a central an objective of his
national policy to be being the
attraction of short-term hot money
that's what Mexico did with the
invention of Tesla Motors that's what
time they did by establishing the
offshore banking facility whose precise
purpose was to attract hot money from
abroad
that's what Brazil did when he consulted
extensively with the hedge fund
community on the design of its financial
instruments that's what Russia did when
they financed its deficit with two weeks
with two week gkos and I could go on
before examines the issue isn't some
kind of notion of controlling capital
flows the issue is that it was the major
objective of national policy to attract
those capital flows and if you don't
like those capital flows the real issue
is what is the national policy in
question and the IMF never gave any
country any advice that it would be a
really good strategy to rely on shorter
and shorter finance the question so
there's a question as to what is the
right strategy with respect to
liberalisation what is the role of
capital controls what types of deposit
should you be willing to accept your
banking system when you have a system
reasonable people can argue about what
the right answer to that question is
it's probably a mistake to be too
Theological about saying that any kind
of bank with any kind of regulation
should be able to take any kind of
deposit but the idea that somehow it's
an international responsibility to
control the flow of capital rather than
a matter of prudence and national
economic management not to borrow not to
do the international equivalent of
financing your kids education on 18
percent credit card 18% revolving credit
card that exceeds to me is just a
pervasive confusion that we need to work
to to to dislodge respective
international institutions there are
plenty of issues I think the IMF could
usefully enhance to some degree focus
its conditionality more effectively than
it has in the past rather than becoming
involved in every area of national
economic policy the IMF sometimes seems
like it stands for it's mostly fiscal
and could usefully as it thinks about
financial crises think about the pattern
that arose in Asia in the 1980 late 90s
where the issues had more to do with the
health of the financial system than they
did with questions of fiscal policy and
that's a capacity that they need to
deliver I think most important is the
enormous ly difficult problem of
thinking through how a international
financial system is going to handle
events default
basically there are two sensible models
you can imagine
for a financial international financial
system with respect to emerging markets
and there's a third that we have it's
not very sensitive one model you could
imagine is the international financial
system would be like the u.s. municipal
market basically countries borrow they
borrow at 1% they borrow it spreads and
plane basis points or 50 basis points or
80 basis points defaults are very rare
when it's a default it's a big crisis
and everybody runs around and deals and
tries to put the thing back together but
defaults are very rare events that's one
type of system you could imagine a
second type of system you could imagine
is a system where there's substantial
borrowing at very high risk premiums 500
basis points seven hundred basis points
800 basis place where there's frequently
the failure to pay after all there
wouldn't be 500 basis point where's
premium unless there was a substantial
risk of the failure to pay and when
there's the failure to pay it sort of
significant for the people involved but
it is not otherwise a major event that's
what happens in the US high-yield
corporate bond market the equilibrium we
have is an equilibrium where at any
given moment you have several dozen
countries borrowing at 500 basis points
500 basis points spreads which imply a
market judgment that there's a well over
50% probability of a default and then
when there is a default everybody points
their fingers at the victims and
declares that they pursued unsound
policies and declares for this financial
nuclear winter and the whole world's got
to get involved in resolving and
cleaning up the crisis and it doesn't
make sense to have a long-run
equilibrium where you have borrowing
with both those elements and that's the
very difficult problem that is at the
center of the IMF submission and working
through it towards one of the two
objectives I described has to be the
primary thrust of thought about the
international
about the IMF party architecture going
forward that's a that's that's obviously
a crucial question and if I were
involved in the official deliberations
on this the answer is I would be so
either to get a deal done that I would
do something in either direction then I
would do something either way if it was
associated with generating some
adjustments my my instant are the the
record of history is that fixed exchange
rates come to grief and so I would
probably rather see a movement towards a
float as the ultimate objective whether
that movement towards a float could
happen today or whether there should be
some intermediate adjustment to some
romantic system along the way is a
question on
I am I am agnostic but the efforts
moving towards flat moving towards more
exchange rate flexibility but not all
the way when you get out of the fixed
exchange rate regime aren't very
encouraging you know one of the
Forgotten men satyr tails associated
with the Mexican financial crisis was
the decision for to devalue but not to
take the risk of floating but simply to
widen the band to a which had been a two
or three percent band it was widened to
ten or fifteen percent but that
accomplished was the loss of half of
Mexico's remaining reserves in two or
three days before that had before that
had to be given up and that was it was
right that it was right to give it up
and in retrospect it would have been
much better to have just floated so I
have an instinct that it is better to
move more quickly towards floating and
less quickly towards complete capital
market liberalization rather than the
direction that the many seem to be
pushing in which is more quickly on
financial market liberalization but
willing to accept some willing to have
exchange rates fixed for longer but
again I think that whatever produced
comfort in terms of the notion of making
some exchange rate adjustment would be
likely to be something that I would be
comfortable
somehow like today even the enormous
complexity that we have seen lately
particularly because the world economy
has a lot of chops over the last four
years which I don't need to release but
today we are having what the highest
growth in the world economy in almost 30
years 5% and is still one of the lowest
inflation rates in modern times
so policymakers don't believe that
things invest in fact and therefore I
don't think they are to women to accept
that some adjustment which have to take
place rather sooner than later so this
very problem problem that they will not
take measures on time and then the
question is what will happen do you
think president solvers the scenario
installation rate calculation
protectionism
even worse laughter International
Monetary coordination is possible any
late really dornbusch wants to say that
things take longer to happen than you
think they will and then they happen
faster than you think I don't think from
now but you look at the trends that I've
described and you somehow think the
music's going to end there's a good
chair for everybody and on the day that
happens US interest rates are likely to
be significantly higher dollars likely
to be significantly lower the Texas
pressures are likely to be significantly
stronger and the world economy is going
to be growing a good deal less rapidly
than it is today
and in many ways some of those
adjustments are going to have to happen
anyway u.s. the band's gonna have to go
down they're gonna have to be some
currency adjustments and the question is
whether those happen or whether those
are completely match whether those are
managed to some degree and I guess my
reading of economic history suggests
with some attempts at management the
outcome is more likely to be
then without the problem of course is
the classic problem with things that are
on sort of - classic problems with
things that are unsustainable one is
just attention to short supply nothing
terrible's happening attention announcer
but there are two other things one is
there are lots of prices that one would
rather see love but not like to see fall
that was the situation that we had
basically he asked us would be healthier
if the stock market was love was lower
than it was yes we want to be in a
position of encouraging it to be falling
though we did well it's very hard for
things to get from higher to lower
without falling so when that's the
situation it can produce it can produce
a kind of paralysis
the second problem for policy makers is
and this is the problem with devaluation
is that if you have painful things have
to happen and manage well then there
will be some pain and unmanaged there
will be a lot of pain the political
capitalist isn't that if I isn't to say
well if we manage this well and there's
some pain everybody will say thank you
very much for magic
well with only some pay and so it
doesn't do all the sin if it manages if
it's unmanaged then there's no one to
blame perhaps there's a whole system to
blame so you know if you take as a
metaphor
the situation of your country as I read
the history you had a problem by
February of 1994 without anybody having
done anything that could be called a
huge mistake you had worked yourself
into a problem where you had a exchange
rate that was predictably unsustainably
high and at the moment that it was
adjusted it was going to be somewhat
economically wrenching and was going to
be quite quite difficult because your
internal politics and in particularly
labor relations were dependent on
someone artificially high level of real
wages caused by that overvalued
exchanger and I think anybody who looked
at it very hard you were not a
government any very clear but a variety
to senior people in your senior people
who were then in your government sort of
looked at it all I think in their heart
of hearts
they wouldn't have argued but the way
they thought about the question yeah
might work out sure so what can I do I
can take an act that is a discretionary
act of mind unforced by circumstance
that
have significant wrenching consequence
or I can let things take their course
there's a prospect that I will work out
that's the deal with it but even with a
poletik for estimate it might work out
it might just become clear so I'll do
what needs to be done but it will be a
forced move rather than a decision of
mine and all of that leads to
significant postponement and so I think
it's the desire to avoid agency with
respect to things that are painful leads
that often lead to the difficulties of
finding these kinds of coordinated you
know he's a different kind of analogy
there's an element to which being
involved in macroeconomic financial
language has a little bit of the
character of being an anesthesiologist
nobody has ever said after surgery is
performed what a fantastic job doing the
anesthesia you sort of assume that you
can be certain it's gonna be anesthesia
it's gonna be okay and so basically the
only occasions on which the anesthesia
anesthesiologist comes to great promise
is on occasions when things screw up and
there's a little bit about that of
financial management in the management
of currencies and all of that basically
it's sort of supposed to work out and
it's supposed to keep on being stable
and so making a bid for prominence is is
sort of counterintuitive for the people
in in those fears and that's why the
adjustments are hard